hey everyone i'm ranita young with quick
take
and budgeting in this pandemic has been
very difficult for
long-term and short-term purposes uh but
today we have anthony o'meal on the
first episode of your money story he's a
millennial
personal finance influencer best-selling
author and
ramsay personality and his story of
overcoming homelessness and debt
hopefully will help you own your money
story anthony
thank you so much for joining us oh man
renita thank you so much for having me
on i've been looking forward to this for
a couple of weeks now so
i can't wait to talk more with you and
serve the people who are watching this
today
great great well let's get right into it
you know i heard something pretty
interesting that you said
recently the caliber of my future will
be determined by the caliber of my
choices but sometimes life also gets in
the way and it builds up on us
and like this current pandemic you know
things happen
we get into a bind like what happened to
you
at 19 years old when you ended up
homeless can you walk us through how you
dug out of that situation well the key
thing for me when i dug out of my
particular homeless situation i was 19
years old 35 000
in debt sleeping in the back of my car
didn't really have a place to go
um and one of the main things that
helped me get out of that situation
really wasn't the practical at first it
was my mindset
i had to really come up with a clear
vision uh with where i wanted to go and
how i wanted to get out
out of debt and so i really changed my
money mindset i got on a clear vision
for my life and then i also got on a
clear
budget that matched the goals that i was
trying to accomplish
so i went and got three jobs i was
working a full-time eight to five
and then a household got a part-time job
washing cars after that and then checked
this out reneta
i was delivering newspapers uh from
around 2am to 4am in the morning
to get some more money why because i was
tired of living
this fake rich life and i really wanted
to start building true wealth
by eliminating my debt getting a clear
vision being intentional
about my decisions so i can have a
brighter future
wow so three jobs pretty much a
full-time job and two side hustles which
even more hours but then you talked
about budgeting how exactly do you
budget now is it the
envelope system that you use accounts
how do you budget now
well you know you know here at ramsey
solutions we talk about the envelope
systems and i'm all [ __ ] i'm all for the
envelope system now i
am a millennial so i do the digital
envelope system
uh through this amazing app that i use
called every dollar and so i pretty much
list all of my income
i list all of my expenses and at the
bottom of that
the issue equals zero so i call this a
zero based
budget through every dollar so for an
example let's say you make two thousand
dollars
um a month that's your income and let's
just say for example you know you have a
rent payment mortgage payment car
insurance utility bills
these are all expenses you know ranita
your hair looks amazing today so i'm
pretty sure you have a hair expense
and so that's an expense you know and so
you want to list all of your expenses
and you want to give every dollar an
assignment i call that you want to put
your vision on paper before the month
begins
and when you get to the bottom of that
it should equal zero
now let's say for an example your your
income is 2 000 but
at the end of your budget you're over by
a hundred so you need to go back to your
budget and make sure that it is
zero at the bottom of it okay got it got
it and
just like we just touched on we're in
the middle of a pandemic the kovid 19
pandemic to be
specific it's upending lives
it's causing an economic slowdown but
walk us through
the steps some people have lost jobs
during them walk us through the steps to
take if you've lost a job
you still have bills and debt yeah you
know rene i want to say this before we
go into that i want to say focus on the
things you can control and don't stress
over the things that you can
all right and here are some of the
things that you can control and that's
your income that you have right
now so when it comes to your budget
here's the first four
things i want you to worry about if
you've lost some particular amount of
income i want you to focus on your food
because we got to keep our bodies and
ourselves healthy
then after that i want you to focus on
your utilities make sure you have hot
water coming into the house make sure
that you have water coming into the
house make sure you have heating
then after that focus on your
transportation okay make sure you have
gas for your car
and then after that focus on your
mortgage or your rent payment
so if you lost anything i don't want you
to worry about nothing else don't worry
about
any collection items you know i want you
to make all of your minimum payments as
much as possible but if you can't
make the minimum payments right now
that's okay i want you to survive
with those four things which i call your
four walls
it protects you all right so again
that's your
food that's gonna be your utilities
that's gonna be your transportation
and that's gonna be your housing so once
you cover those four things and let's
say you have a little bit left over
i just want you to stack that money
don't worry about paying anything else
just start stacking up money so you can
have some some extra margin
to get you through this season but then
also when it comes to budgeting here's
one thing i really want to look at it's
the very first top
that's your income all right so right
now if you have lost a job
what i want you to do is go out there
and try and figure out how can you bring
in some extra cash for an example you
can do online learning there are a lot
of students right now
who are working from home doing school
from home
and parents are sitting at home stress
they don't know how to do math
they don't know how to do english and so
right now what you can do is just figure
out
how you can bring in some extra income
from online learning
make sure maybe grocery shopping uh
maybe even some food delivery services
but that's how you really control a
pandemic
budget got it got it and on the flip
side
a lot of people have been working from
home and they have been stacking a
little extra cash
yeah how do you suggest they make the
best of that money
you know i go back to the baby steps so
if you still do have some income coming
in great all right and if you still have
debt i want you to go to babysit number
two which is pay off all your debt
using the debt snowball and especially
right now renita
i mean the president and congress has
went ahead and um
not forgiven but they've delayed student
loan payments and they've cut off
interest until the end of the year
december 31st
so let's say right now you only have
student loans and you have income coming
in
right now go ahead and start attacking
that so you're not making
any extra payments and you're not paying
any extra interest
um at this present time so take
advantage of this
season to pay off your debt but let's
just say you don't have any debt
let's say um you have a fully funded
emergency fund
now was a great time to go ahead and
start investing
start looking into a roth um ira invest
into a growth stock mutual fund
um start looking and investing into a
401k and maxing out with those benefits
but if you're working from home
i'm going to simply say a roth ira or
talk to a smart investor someone who can
help you out with financial services
and help you figure out how to start
investing as an entrepreneur
all right now you mentioned college loan
debt and a lot of people have
a lot of college loan debt they might
even call college loan debt
a pandemic of its own now since people
have been given this um this delay in
payments from federal
loans what should they consider before
they consider whether or not
to actually delay the payment is it
contingent upon
how much debt they have walk us through
what people should think about
so if i'm in their shoes let's say for
an example i'm in debt and i'm starting
this journey and i have student loans
right now federal student loans
the federal student loan interest rate
is 4.5 right now that's what the going
rate is
if that's the only debt that i have
let's say i still have a good income
coming in let's say i've averaged 58 000
per year i am going to attack the debt
okay i'm not going to take the advantage
of just letting the student loans just
sit there because what's happening is
it's sitting there
yes it's not gaining any interest but
here's where the wealthy get wealthy
they take
advantages they take advantage of the
seasons where they can win
and right now is a great season for you
to win
you can pay back the principal without
paying back any interest
and so the normal people the average
people
no i don't want average people uh to to
do this i want you to become
an uh pretty much a superb individual
and take advantage of this season and
attack
all of your debt and take advantages of
all these breaks that we're getting
right now in america
and on that note is it a good time we
have a question from the audience
and is it a good investment to take out
student loans
during this uncertain time no it's not a
good it's not a good investment to
borrow any money right now
i don't care what anyone says no you're
not taking out student loans
you're not taking out car loans um the
only loan i am okay with if you are
properly and proudly prepared for this
is a mortgage but we're going to do that
on a 15-year
fixed-rate mortgage and so but no
taking out student loans right now is
not wise
at all taking out credit cards is
not wise at all right now the best thing
you can do for your money
is think about your future and your
future is saying
please come into me debt free so the
best thing you can do right now is pay
off all of your debt
go ahead and get you a fully funded
emergency fund
and some people i know are thinking
saying well hey oh um i have a credit
card for an emergency
no no no i want you to have cash for
your emergency i want you to stay out of
debt so you can start building
margin in your life and you can build a
solid foundation for your future
a lot of people are also talking about
shifting their careers during this time
i just talked to a friend who quit his
job um
and many people are looking to innovate
start their own businesses
what kind of financial advice do you
give for those folks
you know one thing about
entrepreneurship that i love it brings
freedom
freedom brings power and so i encourage
anyone if you know you are
called to entrepreneurship if you
believe that you can be a great
entrepreneur
then go for it right now i'm gonna
i'm gonna say move slowly don't try and
jump out there
and borrow money to start your business
my mentor dave ramsey
started very slowly and today look at
him you know he has built
a huge empire from borrowing
zero dollars and so what i'm
recommending to entrepreneurs is get on
the budget make sure that you have a
budget
for your life and then make sure you
have a budget for your business
okay that's number one number two have a
clear vision okay this is where i want
to be at by this time this year
this is where i want to be at by january
of next year and
slowly go there and then here's number
three quit the comparison game
and get around some other influential
entrepreneurs
who have done what you have what you're
trying to do
okay ask them all the right questions
ask them you know hey what should i be
doing what should i
not be doing how should i take advantage
of this season
because studies have shown in previous
pandemics in previous
market crashes that a lot of
millionaires were made during that time
but they were made during that time
because they got around the wise people
and they listened more than they taught
and so i would definitely recommend that
uh during this season got it okay so
couple
rapid fire questions for you rapid fire
let's go
okay let's go what is your biggest
financial accomplishment so far
um i just sold my first home and and
bought my
second home which is a very nice
very good okay second one um you have a
pretty interesting anecdote this is not
a quick rapid fire question
pretty interesting anecdote about dating
and budgeting
yes please tell everybody about it hey
man my whole thing is this
um when it comes to dating and budgeting
my whole philosophy is
on your budget you should have a line
item for dating and you should not go
over it so brothers if a young lady
doesn't want to date you
because you only have a hundred dollars
set aside for budgeting that month
uh then that's that's that's on her
that's her loss uh but i do believe
that it is okay for a woman to pay for
your meal every now and then
you know and if it's if it's within her
budget
but i do believe that two people dating
you should have the same mindset and the
same mindset is this
we want to build wealth and we do want
to have a budget and a vision for our
money
so that's not a rapid-fire question it's
not but
you have a story about this experience
i do i do you know i was talk to us in
one minute
i could tell too in 30 seconds i was
turned down
um i was denied a second date because
she asked me to go to a particular
restaurant
that restaurant was over my budget for
the month
i didn't tell her no i just told her
next month i can i can take you there
when i text her that back she never
responded then when she saw me on tv
something like this she was like yo i
didn't know you was this big
what about that second date and i never
responded to her
and that was probably a little childish
on my end but she played me and i was
like let me play you back a little bit
but i've matured and grown since then
and uh but that that's my story
when it comes to budget all right i just
needed the context everyone needed the
contacts
um so then from that what was the
biggest
financial mistake you see people making
in relationships
uh the biggest financial mistake that i
see people especially young people
making
relationships is they try to hang with
people what they with people
and things they see on instagram and so
if they see that this
young lady has the latest louis vuitton
purse oh they go get the louis vuitton
purse
um if they see they traveled here they
want to go do that
rather than just focusing on yourself
and on your goals and your visions and
just running your
race i posted that this morning on my
instagram
and i say you know it feels good when
you don't have to worry about someone
else's life and you just focus on your
life
there's so much peace there's so much
joy there's so much freedom in that
and so one of the biggest mistakes i see
young people making when it comes to
dating and budgeting is they try to live
the life
of instagram of social media rather than
just slowly growing a solid foundation
for yourself
and being grateful for the season that
you're in right now
okay okay and we're getting ready to
wrap it up and if you have the extra
time
do please give it we have to talk about
building generational wealth in the
community
uh now as we know um after a minneapolis
police officer killed george floyd
over this summer it was a huge uh black
lives matter
movement a huge bi black movement that's
one way
to create wealth generational wealth and
black communities what are some other
ways
you know i love that you know um just to
be honest with you you know i moved from
columbia south carolina and i moved to
the black community that was something
that i was personally
convicted by that a lot of successful
african americans leave the community
and i said i want to go back and give in
to my community another way we can help
the black community is bringing two
things financial education and emotional
intelligence
i think the one of the main reasons why
uh the black community is struggling
financially is because we are not really
taught how to deal with our emotions
correctly
and so if we see something if we're
bothered by something we respond off of
that and we go get
that and so for me that's one thing i
believe we can bring financial
intelligence into our high schools in
emotional intelligence into our high
schools that will help out the
african-american community
and then three the last things when it
comes to the african-american community
when it comes to building wealth
we got to keep our dollars within the
community you know i'm always looking
for
small businesses that i can support uh
within the community
um as much as possible i'm not saying
i'm going 100
into the african-american community uh
but i believe in sharing it all you know
i work for a
predominantly white uh business and
great business
but if i could find a african-american
to wash my cars if i could find an
african-american grocery store you know
i'm going to support as much as i
possibly can
but here's the main thing when it comes
to us we got to stop blaming everyone
else
there are some things that we need
systems to change
we need some policies to change but at
the same time
we got to change our mindset in how we
look at things okay
i mean i think for me that's the main
thing that i'm focusing on i'm not
focusing on the white house
i'm going to focus on my house what can
i do better
to be a good steward over the resources
that i have
and i know this is not a christian
organization a christian show
but as a man of faith i believe that god
can give me
more money as long as i'm a good steward
of what i have so i'm focusing on what
i'm doing
then i'm focusing on how i'm bringing
income back into my community
all right i think that's a great place
to leave it anthony o'neil thank you so
much for joining us and
if any of you have any questions about
personal finance
you can find anthony on any of his
twitter or
facebook or instagram handles at anthony
o'neil
or you could also and you could also
make sure to send
us a comment right down below because
we'll be doing your money story
more so thanks a lot for joining us
with bloomberg quick take i'm renita
young everyone have a wonderful day